in Verbier it's simply referred to as
the lodge richard branson's personal
holiday home in the swiss alps and it's
open to rent oh good to meet you let's
take a look come on
with room for 18 guests it's more like a
luxury hotel than a hideaway in the
mountains a staff of 54 chefs a spa
therapist and a 24 hour driver service
and then more personal touches
downstairs is set up for the ultimate
and operate a fully stocked bar and even
a dance floor with a disco ball the pool
isn't far you trying to discourage
drunken antics in the pool see it's its
own boy it's quite dangerous but there
are two of us here if it does lead to a
pool party then we will be here to make
sure that no one stray too far from
what's below with a large living room
quiet Suites and a bunk room for the
kids at hosts corporate getaways family
reunions in the Branson clam okay we're
going into Richard's suite here see
what's inside ceilings are a bit low but
there's a remote-controlled fireplace
not everyone who stays here knows this
but given that it's Richards room there
has to be a surprise and in this case
it's a secret passageway behind the
bookshelf we open it up this leads into
the neighboring suite where you can have
some peace and quiet
maybe get some work done when you're on
your ski holiday rooms are available to
rent individually but if you want the
whole place to yourself you'll need a
CEO salary like Sir Richard's Christmas
week will set you back over one hundred
and eighty thousand dollars so the lodge
is popular with corporate groups to
impress clients and let loose with one
important decree a mountain lodge that
isn't as pure as the virgin snow outside
Hans Nichols Bloomberg there we go
you